you think the playoffs or a gift you get  every year  you think the guys of this game have a  soft spot for those pretty hazel eyes  it's here and it's gone boy one minute  you're in the dance but the next year on  the Timberwolves and just stuck prayin  for ping-pong balls for the rest of your  forgotten career the Wizards are getting  stronger John Wall is no longer a boy  and they're coming for our rings you're  the best player in borås and you're  afraid of some scrubs from washing fell  dynasties for Lord Riley ah dynasties  for but you're forgetting one thing we  have dragons  my knees Meister Cole said I'm out for  the season  what if I never play again busy as the  trade stipulates you must take one of my  daughters my daughter Jody my daughter  Jordan my daughter Chris or my daughter  Weasley it's Wesley shut up I saw would  be a noise Russell the comic Russell  calm down who's coming the Spurs  [Music]  [Music]  you